[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعله اخرى هذه الصور للبيت الابيض في
واشنطن هناك يستعد الرئيس الامريكيين
ليلقي كلمه الليله لتعقيب على مشهد
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونجرس نتوقعها
في الثانيه عشر بتوقيت الدوحه
مشهد الانتخابات لم ينتهي وهنا نشاهد من
نيفادا مؤتمرا صحفيا بشان نتائج التصويت
ونحن نتحدث عن احدى ولايات الحصن نيفادا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله كذلك
الولايات المتحده توصل فرز الاصوات في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونغرس رغم
تقدميين في مجلس النواب الجمهوريون
يخالفون توقعات ويعجزون عن تحقيق موجه
الاكتساح والمنافسه مع الديمقراطيين
محتدمه في مجلس الشيوخ ولايه جورجيا
ونيفادا ورقتا الحسم النهائي
[موسيقى]
خيرسون واشهد يزداد غموضا بعد اجلاء
سكانها القوه الروسيه تعلن الانسحاب وتقيم
خط دفاعا جديده كيف تشكك في الخطوه وتقول
انها ستحدد موقفها بناء على الافعال
الاقوال ومسك تقول انوشنت تتحمل مسؤوليه
اطاله امد الصراع واستنزافي اوروبا
الضفه الغربيه على واقع التوتر يتصاعد
قوات الاحتلال اقتحامات في نابلس وجنين
وتقتل فلسطينيين وتعتقل اخرين
مع الترقب لولاده حكومه توصف بالاكثر
يمينيه في تاريخ الصراع
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مشهد الترقب المستمر
للنتائج النهائيه لانتخابات التجديد
النصفي في الولايات المتحده احد المترقبين
كنا اوكرانيا التي حظيت بدعم امريكيا كبير
خلال الحرب هذا الدعم قابلته تصريحات بانك
يجب ان لا تتوقع شيتا على بياض بشان الدعم
في حال نجاح الحزب الجمهوري في الفوز
بالاغلبيه
رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم
السؤال الثاني برايكم كيف ستنعكس نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه على سياسه
واشنطن تجاهها الحرب في اوكرانيا
30% قالوا انها ستتغير اذا ما فاز
الجمهوريون بالاغلبيه في حين راى 20% هل
لن تتغير حتى لو حصل الجمهوريون على
الاغلبيه
50% رجحوا انها ستتغير حتى لو حافظ
الديمقراطيون على الاغلبيه
[موسيقى]
طبعا هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكن دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
من هذا الحديث عن انعكاسات الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه الى تفاصيل المشهد مع
ال سي ابو عاصي ونفذ لمتابعه النتائج من
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك ليلى اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
النافذه الجديده من العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن نوصل فيها تغطياتنا لنتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه ومازلنا في انتظار حسن
السيطره على الكونجرس بمجلسيه مع استمرار
فرز الاصوات في عدد من الولايات النتائج
الاوليه تظهر ان الجمهوريين لم يحققوا
الفوز الكبير الذي توقعته استطلاعته الراي
في الايام الاخيره
هذه هي الصوره في مجلس النواب تقدم للحزب
الجمهوري لكن ايا من الحزبين لم يحقق
الاغلبيه حتى اللحظه الجمهوريون امالو
2004 مقاعد مقابل 176
للديمقراطيين
وتطلب الاغلبيه الحصول على 2008
اما في مجلس الشيوخ فتقدم الحزب الجمهوري
ب49 مقعدا بعد فوزهم في وسكن قبل ساعات
مقابله 48
للديمقراطيين وبينما لم يتم لم يتم الحسم
بعد في ولايه اريزونا ونفاذا تحول سباق في
جورجيا الى جوله ثانيه
وتتطلب قوانين ولايه جورجيا ان يتخطى
المرشح حاجزا 50% ليفوز بمقعد مجلس الشيوخ
وهو ما لم يحدث فقد صوت
49.4% لصالح السنه راديمقراطيه الوورك
مقابل
48.5% لصالح منافسه الجمهوري هيرشال
بنسبه للمقاعد التي لم تحسم في مجلس
الشيوخ في الريزونا المتارجحه اظهرت
النتائج تقدم الديمقراطيين على الجمهوريين
في السباق لمقعد مجلس الشيوخ ووافقا نيه
تلك النتائج فقد نال سنه الديمقراطيه
واحدا
51.4% من الاصوات مقابله سته واربعين فاصل
4% لمنافسه الجمهوريه
اما في ولايه نيفادا فقد اظهرت النتائج
تقدما للجمهوريين في السباق على مجلس
الشيوخ بعد فرز نحو سبعه وسبعون في المئه
من الاصوات وحاز المرشح الجمهوري ادم
لاكسوس على
49.9 من الاصوات مقابله سبعه واربعين
فاصله اثنين في المئه
الديمقراطيه كاسرنج كورتيز ماستو
اما في ولايه بنسلفانيا فسيطر
الديمقراطيون على مقعد حاسما في معركه
السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ بفوز على المرشح
مهنه اوز المدعومي من الرئيس السابق
كان يشغله عضو جمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ
ينضموا الي تنضم الينا شبكه مراسلين في
انحاء الولايات المتحده معنا من المجلس
التشريعي المحلي لمدينه اتلانتا في ولايه
جورجيا مراسل الجزيره احمد هزيم من المركز
الرئيسي لفرز الاصوات في مقاطعه ماريكوبا
في مدينه فينكس في اريزونا مراسله الجزيره
بيسان ابو كويك من لاس فيغاس في ولايه
نيفادا معنا مراسل الجزيره فادي منصور
مرحبا بكم جميعا سنبدا من جورج احمد هزيم
اذا الولايه تتجه الى جوله اعاده ماذا في
التفاصيل
نعمل سي كما كان متوقعا ستذهب هذا سيذهب
هذا السباق الى جوله اعاده نظرا لكون
موجود مرشح ثالث
اوليفر مرشح حزب البرتيرن والذي حاز على
80 الف صوت ماذا الان بعد ان اتجهت هذه
السباق على هذا المقعر المهم في مجلس
الشيوخ الى جوله اعاده السادس من ديسمبر
ها يستعد الطرفان الى حملات انتخابيه
جديده هناك قسمان او تحليلان قسم يرى ان
رافاييل وورد وهو السنترا الديمقراطي الذي
اداراه حمله قائمه على الاعتدال وليس على
اقصى اليسار في الحزب وتعهد بالتعاون مع
الجمهوريين لما له صالح العام لولايه
جورجيا و للولايات المتحده يعتقد لمراقبنا
انه هو الاكثر قدره على انتزاع اصوات التي
ذهبت الى
الجمهوريون يرى بعض المراقبين قريبين من
الجمهوريين
هو جمهوري وحزب البريطاني قريب جدا من
الحزب الجمهوري سيحظى هو باغلبيه الاصوات
من تشيز اوليفر هناك قسم ايضا يرى بان
الحمل التي ادارها التي كانت قائمه اساسا
على الترامبيه السياسيه هي تنثر من صوته
الى جيس اوليفر وفي الغالب اما سيصودون
للديمقراطيس رفيع الورد او سيبقون في
البيوت دون التصويت في جوله الاعاده ال سي
اذا كان هناك مرشحان فالمرشح الفائز بال-
باكثر عدد من الاصوات هو من سيفوز بهذا
المقعد سيكون التنافس حاميا بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين هنا نتوقع ان
تدخل اموال الدعايه السياسيه والدعايه
الانتخابيه في هذه الولايه اذا لم يتمكن
الديمقراطيون من حسم ولايتي نيفادا
واريزونا ان هما حسما ولايه نيفادا
واريزونا فلن يحتاجوا الى هذا المقطع
سيحتفظون باللغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ من دون
الانتظار نتيجه حاسم ولايه جورجيا حتى
اللحظه هم متاخرون فينا بعد ومتقدمون في
ولايه اريزونا ولذلك يبدو هذا السباق
بالنسبه للديمقراطيين مصيري للغايه
للاحتفاظ بالاغلبيه خصوصا وان حظوظهم في
النفاده نوعا ما ليست كحظوظهم في اريزونا
بالنسبه الى ايضا الجمهوريه الذين ينظرون
الى سباق هيرش الووكر مقارنه مع نظرائه
الجمهوريين فازوا بنسبه مريحه سواء كانت
على مستوى حاكم الولايه بين براين كامبو
او حتى على مستوى سكرتيره الولايه
الجمهور يرون ان هؤلاء راسو
من السياسيين الجمهوريين الذي عاداهم
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بعد ان رفضوا
تلبيه الطلبه بقلبي نتائج الانتخابات هنا
في ولايه جورجيا ونتذكر المكالمه الشهيره
التي تم نشرها في وسائل اعلام انا ذاك بين
الرئيس الامريكي وبين
والذي طلب منه الرئيس الامريكي ايجاد 11
11000 صوت و118 صوت انتخابي لتفوق على
الفارق بينه وبين الرئيس همم جو بايدن
انذاك هؤلاء فازوا بارياحيه كبرى هير ووكر
المدعوم من ترامب والذي قد شارك معه من
الحملات الانتخابيه هنا والفعاليات
الانتخابيه في ولايه جورجيا لم يؤدي بذات
الاداء الذي ادوهم وهذا مؤشر اخر
للجمهوريين لان ربما التنبيه السياسيه هي
من عطلت موجتهم الحمراء الذي كانوا
يتوقعونها في انتخابات التسجيل النصفي وان
هذا السباق سباق مقعد الشيوخ هذا هو ايضا
هو ايضا جزء من هذا التعطيل جزء من عدم
قدرتهم على حسم المساله مبكرا حسب المساله
دون دون الخوف في جوله عاده في السادس من
ديسمبر وحسم الاغلبيه حتى في مجلس الشيوخ
ومجلس النواب ربما كانت الترامبيه
السياسيه من في بعض المناطق هنا في ولايه
جورجيا تحديدا ربما اعاقتهم لتحقيق هذه
الاغلبيه التي يرغبون بها
الالز
ون بيسان ترقب لي النتائج في اريزونا على
مستويات مستوى مقعد مجلس الشيوخ وايضا
حاكميه الولايه ماذا تقول الارقام الفرز
حتى الان لنا
ارقام الفارس حتى الان ما زال هناك في هذه
المقاطعه تحديدا اكبر مقاطعه واكثرها
كثافه سكانيه في هذه الولايه اكثر من
400,000 قائمه اقتراع يتم
احتسابها وفرشها مقسمه الى جزئين الجزء
الاول نحو ميتاتين وخمسه وسبعين الف قسمه
اقتراح تم ادلاء بها ضمن ما يعرف
بالاقتراع المبكر ولكن سلم مع همم اغلاق
مراكز الاختراع في هذه الولايه الجزء
الاخر هو الاصوات التي تم التصويت فيها
بشكل شخصي في مراكز الاقتراع يوم الاقتراع
طبعا نحن في مركز الفرز الرئيسي كما ترون
خلفي هناك عمليات
لمراجعه
القسائم وهذه الاجهزه التي خلف ايضا هي
التي تستخدم في عمليه احتساب الاصوات
اليوم تم التاكد من الامضاءات وبدات
عمليات الاحتساب والفرس حتى الان يتقدم
الستاره ديمقراطيه ماركالي بنحو 90,000
صوت على منافسه الجمهوري بلايك ماستر ز
رغم ان ماستر يضيق الفجوه همم به وبا كالي
ولكن كاليه يبدو انه واثق من انه سيحافظ
على مقعده في مجلس الشيوخ فيما يتعلق
بحاكميه الولايه مساء امس نتائج الاوليه
التي وصلت يعني اظهرت خارجا كبيرا ما بين
الديمقراطيه كيتي التي كانت متقدمه مقارنه
بمنافستها الجمهوريه همم همم
ولكن الان معه ورود
نتائج اللي التصويت الشخصي ونتائج من
مقاطعات اخرى في هذه الولايه تميل اكثر
الى الحزب الجمهوري بات الفارق فقط ما بين
10,000 صوت فقط وما زال طبعا متقدمه ولكن
هناك توقعات ان هذا قد تغير كل ما اقتربنا
من نهايه عمليه الاحتساب همم ما قاله لنا
مسؤولون هنا ان عمليه الاحتساب همم ستنتهي
يعني ربما يوم الجمعه يتوقعون ان يتم
احتساب 95 في المئه من الاصوات والقسائم
التي بحوزتهم الان هناك طبعا دائما همم
بطاقات اخرى يتم حسابها قد يكون شابها بعض
المشاكل وهذا يتطلب وقتا اكثر ولكن 95%
ايه يترقبها المسؤولون هنا بحلول يوم
الجمعه لدى السعاده المقبله هي ساعات هامه
جدا وارسي ربما نكرر هذه المساله الكم
الاعلامي الموجود هنا همم محليه وعلى
الصعيد الوطني وعلى الصعيد الدولي المحتشد
هنا لان هذه الولايه باتت هي الولايه التي
ستحسم ربما من الولايات التي ستحسم نتيجه
سيطره مجلس الشيوخ فيما يتعلق باترافيه
سيا لربما السؤال حول ما اذا كانت قد
تتلاشى الان هذه ترامبيا السياسيه ربما
اريزونا قد تحمل اجابه مختلفه في حال
تمكنت كاريك وهي رمز جديد لهذه تربي
سياسيه من ان تحرز هدفها بتولي منصب حاكمه
الولايه مع نهايه الفرز نعم لتحول الى
فادي منصور في نيفادا ايضا فادي هناك سباق
محموم من الذي يتقدم حتى الان في المنافسه
على مقعد
بين ليله امس واليوم انقلبت الايه يوم امس
كان ديمقراطيون يتقدمون فيها المنافسه على
مقعد مجلس الشيوخ والدفاع عن هذا المقعد
الذي تحتله مرشحتهم وعضو مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكيه سنهور كورتيز ماستو بمواجهه
المدعوم المرشح الجمهوريه المدعوم من قبل
الرئيس دونالد ترامب لكن افقنا صبيحه
اليوم على معادله مختلفه تقدم نحو 25000
صوت للاجزالت على المرشح كورتيز مايسترو
لكن ال سي هذه صوره جزئيه يدركها الطرفان
وكان حذرين للغايه رغم ان كل طرف
الديمقراطي والجمهوريه اعرب عن ثقته بانه
سوف يفوز بهذه الانتخابات لان احدا لم
يتجرا على الاعلان عن فوز سابق لاوانه
لماذا لان هناك العديد من الاصوات التي
يجب ان تحصى ولم يتم احصائها لا سيما هنا
في مقاطعه كلا حيث توجد مدينه لاس فيغاس
وهي اكبر مقاطعه سكانيه في الولايه والتي
تحمل خزان الاصوات بالاضافه الى مقاطعه
وشو حيث تقع مدينه رينو في هاتين
المقاطعتين هناك اصوات كثيره اكثر من
200,000 صوت لم تحتسب بعد والفار والفارق
لا يزال ضئيل بين المتنافسين الديمقراطي
والجمهوري قبل قليل وخلال مؤتمر صحفي هنا
في مقاطعه كلارك قال المسؤول عن احتساب
الاصوات كفكره همم ماذا تقارب هذه المعركه
وما هو على المحك هذا حتى هذه اللحظه وحجم
الاصوات التي لم تحصى ان هناك نحو خمسه
الاف صوت تقريبا من الاصوات التي ينبغي ان
يتم تصحيحها اضافه الى ذلك هناك نحو خمسه
الاف صوت من الاصوات المؤقته اي انها سوف
تحسم السلطات اذا كانت سوف تحتسب ام لا
فضلا عن ذلك اليوم فقط وصل اكثر من اثنين
عشر الف صوت مما نقترعه في البريد ولا
يزال امام المقاطعه هنا حتى يوم السبت
لتلقي جميع الاصوات البريديه
انها مؤرخه بيوم الانتخابات اي يوم الثامن
من نوفمبر وبالتالي كل هذه الاصوات وما
تبقى منها قد تغير المعادلات وعلى هذا
الاساس هناك انتظار وفي دلاله على حجم
تقارب الفرص ما بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين التمس اليوم الحزب
الديمقراطيطي من قواعده هنا في نيفادا لمن
صوت وهناك اشكالات تحيط بصوته اي يذهب الى
السلطات لكي يصححوا الاخطاء وبالتالي هناك
ادراك بانك كل صوت له اهميه في هذه
المعركه وان نيفادا لن تكشف عن الورقه
الرابحه قبل ايام اذا كانت استمرت المعركه
بشكل متقارب للغايه ما لم يحسم احد
المرشحين بشكل كبير المعركه اما هنا في
تحديدا هنا في مقاطعه كلارك ومن ثم في
مقاطعه وبالتالي ينبغي ان ننتظر المزيد
لنعرف لمن سيذهب مقعد مجلس الشيوخ في
نيفادا شكرا
فهد مراسلنا فادي منصور واشكر من المجلس
التشريعي في ولايه جورجيا مراسلنا احمد
هزيم ومن مقاطعه مريكوبا في ولايه ارينا
مراسلتنا بيسان ابو كويك
تاريخيا شكلت الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه التي تجرى في منتصف ولايه
الرئيس محطه لتصويت عقبي ضد حزبه فلم يحدث
ان فاز فيها حزب الرئيس الا مرتين من
اجمالي 17 موعدا انتخابيا منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثالثه يطرح يطرح عدم تحقيق
الجمهوريين فوزا كبيرا في الانتخابات
الحاليه اسئله بشان الواقع السياسي
والاقتصادي والاجتماعيه الامريكي الذي قد
يجعل منها استثناء ان يخالف القاعده
لم يحدث المد الاحمر الذي توعد به
الجمهوريون باتجاه الانتخابات النصفيه الى
وضع المتارجح لا يمنح انتصارا صريحا للحزب
الجمهوري فان احد اكثر الانماط ثباتا في
التاريخ السياسي الامريكي في الطريق لان
يكسر وهي خساره حزب الرئيس بعد سنتين من
توله منصبه اعتاد الناخبون الامريكيون
اتخاذ هذا الموعد الانتخابي فرصه للتصويت
في ما يشبه الاستفتاء على شعبيه الرئيس
فبعد عامين على وصول الديمقراطي باراك
اوباما الى البيت الابيض عام 2008 خسر
الديمقراطيون 63 مقعدا في مجلس النواب
خلال انتخابات التجديد النصفي عام 2010
وعلى نحو الممثل ومعهود خسر الحزب
الجمهوري واحدا واربعين مقعدا في مجلس
النواب عام 2018 اي بعد سنتين من انتخاب
دونالد ترامب رئيسا للبلاد
وعلى امتداري تاريخ الانتخابات في
الولايات المتحده منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه عام
1945 الى اليوم خسر حزب الرئيس في 17
موعدا للانتخابات النصفيه التي تجرى في
منتصف الولايات الرئاسيه من اجماليه 19
موعدا انتخابيه كانت تصويت في جل
الانتخابات اجراء عقابيا يقره الناخب
الامريكي في حق الرئيس
عاده ما تتدنى نسب شعبيه الرؤساء في منتصف
ولاياتهم الرئاسيه فاذا كانت نسبه شعبيه
بعيدا حاليا في حدود الاربعين في المئه
فان نسب المماثله حصل عليها سلفه دونالد
ترامب عام 2018 وبارك اوباما عام 2010
وقبلهما بالكليتون عام
بات الطريق سالكا الى كسر القاعده محاطه
بعوامل مؤثره على خيارات الناخب جرت
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه هذه السنه
فالمناخ السياسي استثنائيون الى حد كبير
في ظل مخاوف على الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
لاسيما وان ميول بعض المرشحين الجمهوريين
واضحه نحو التطرف الى اقصى اليمين يضاف
الى ذلك قضايا اجتماعيه ملحه تشغل المواطن
الامريكي وعلى راسها الحق في الاجهاض الذي
ابتله قرار للمحكمه العليا شهر يونيو
الماضي ويبدي الحزب الديمقراطي نزوعا نحو
السعاده
معنا في الاستوديو هنا في واشنطن جول روبن
محلل الجزيره لشؤون الانتخابات ومساعد
وزير الخارجيه الاسبق لشؤون الكونجرس
والقيادي في الحزب الديمقراطي معنا ايضا
في الاستوديو رون نارين محلل الجزيره
لشؤون الانتخابات والقيادي في الحزب
الجمهوري مرحبا بكما وايضا ضيفنا السيد
محمد المنشاوي الباحث المختص في الشؤون
الامريكيه مرحبا بكم جميعا سنبدا معكم
محمد المنشاوي كيف يمكن تقييم حسابات
الربح والخساره فيما التاليه حتى الان هذه
الانتخابات نتائجها
الفائز الاهم هو الرئيس كل توقع موقع
حمراء طاغيه اا يخسر فيها الحزب
الديمقراطي بسبب عدم ارتفاع نسبه شعبيه
بنسبه كبيره في مجلس همم النواب وبنسب
بسيطه في مجلس الشيوخ لكن الصوره همم ليست
همم بهذه همم نتائج ليست بهذه الصوره حتى
الان على الجانب الجمهوري الخاسر الاكبر
اعتقد هو كيس السابق دونالد ترامب الذي
همم
اعطى لنفسه الثناء والفضل للفوز الكبير
والموجه الحمراء الطاغيه التي توقعها وهذا
لم يحدث واعترضنا الفائز الاهم في الجانب
الجمهوري هو حاكم ولايه فلوريدا همم روندي
سانتوس الذي خرج امس منتصرا انتصارا كاسحا
بعيدا عن اي نفوز او دعم من الرئيس السابق
دون ترامب واعترض ان همم النتائج في
الجانب الجمهور ستكون بدايه شرخ همم سنراه
في الايام والاسابيع القادمه شرخ الكبير
في الحزب الجمهوري واعتقد ان سيكون هناك
مراجعه لدور
طغيان الرئيس ترامب على الحسبه والمؤسسات
والمختلف
لماذا لم يستطع الجمهوريون تحقيق هذه
الموجه الحمراء ما الذي منع ذلك
احد الاسباب هناك اسباب كثيره لكن الاهم
لم يفصلوا بين همم دور ترامب والنفوذ داخل
الكتله الجمهوريه في الانتخابات التمهيديه
والتي كان لها نفوز كبير فيها في دعم بعض
المرشحين وقت تسهم الانتخابات التمهيديه
في بعض الولايات لكن على المستوى الولايه
الكامله وهناك الكثير من ان المصوتين
المستقلين الذين كان يجب على الجمهوريين
ان يخففوا من حده خطابهم اليمين المتشدد
لجذبهم الى جانبهم لكن هذا لم يحدث واعتنا
المرشحين الترامبيين استعملوا نفسه لغه
خطاب الحملات التمهيديه وهذا افقادم
الكثير من اصوات المستقلين الذين كانوا في
حاجه اليهم في هذه الدوره امس
لماذا لم تتحقق الموجه الحمراء التي همم
الجمهوريون يعملون ان تتحقق ويتوقعون ان
تتحقق
اعتقد ان العوامل
متعدده نحن بحاجه الى
مرشحين من جوده المرتفعه في المقاطعات
والولايات
التنافسيه هناك الانتخابات التمهيديه التي
تؤدي بشكل اوتوماتيكي الى ان يكسبوا في
الانتخابات ولكن 10% من النتائج تشدد على
اهميه الشخصيات الكبيره من الترشيحات
بنسبه الى الجمهوريين اذا لم تكن حملاتهم
جيده وهم ادعوا الى الحاق الضرر وايضا
الخصم في اي حمله يقوم بتشتيتنا ويجب ان
لا نشتت الذات من خلال تصريحات لا تاتي
بالفعل هذا اولا النقطه الثانيه برايه
ارتكب خطا بعد السادس من يناير الجمهوري
هناك كان يجب بشكل عام واسع نطاق من دون
اي مجالا لسوء التفسير كان يجب ان يدين
الشخص شارك في ما حصل في الكابتل من دون
محاوله اي تبرير وضع حد لذلك هذا لم يحصل
بعد المرحله الاولى واعضاء من الحزب كانوا
يلتفون حول الرئيس ترامب وهو كان يبرر
الافعال التي حصلت في الكابتل هذا ادى الى
الحاق الضرر وادى الى وضعا ليس لصالح
الجمهوريين هذه الانتخابات الوطنيه الاولى
بعد السادس من يناير وكل البلاد عبرت عن
رايها وهذا امر شتت ولكن هذا لن يمنع ان
يكون مجلس النواب بجمهوريا وقد نحصل على
مجلس الشيوخ جمهوريه طبعا ما من مد او
موجه اذا هناك خساره ديمقراطيه في مجلس
النواب لربما في مجلس الشيوخ ننتظر جورج
اه جو روبن كما قال رونالدو هذه ليست موجه
حمراء ولكنها ليست هزيمه لماذا لا يتعامل
الحزب الديمقراطي معها كذلك خصوصا انه
يقول ان الحزب الجمهوري يتجه كما يبدو من
الارقام الى السيطره على مجلس النواب
الانتخابات هي خيبه امل بالنسبه الى
الجمهوريه بالنسبه الى الديمقراطيين هذا
انتصارا معنوي مهم وانتصار على مستوى مجلس
الشيوخ مجلس النواب ان نتيجه متقاربه وكما
قال هناك بعض المرشحين
المحددين في بنسلفانيا في رزونا في
وسكانسن هناك شخص
المعادن الديمقراطيه خسره الشعب الامريكي
ورفضهم مرعيناهم بنسبه الى الديمقراطيين
وهي نقطه اساسيه الديمقراطيون هم تحالف
هناك همم مصالح متعدده في بعض الاحيان تعم
الفوضى او تقتله الامور ولكن هناك تنوع
هناك الجيل الجديد الذي صوت
بنسبه 70% قال حد الديموقراطيين المستقلون
صوتوا لصالح الديمقراطيين بنقطه الى
نقطتين وهو شكل صدمه في التجديد النصفي
بالاضافه الى ذلك الاجهاض كان مساله
اساسيه
الديمقراطيون السلط الضوء على هذه النقطه
سبع من اصل 10 ممن يهتم بهذه المساله صوت
لصالح الديمقراطيه هذه المسائل الحاضره
والجو بايدن هو الرابح الاكبر
لم يجر الحزب الى الخلف هو اواجه حسابات
التقليديه يمكنه ان يقول انه زعيم الفريق
في مقابل التشتت على مستوى الحزب الجمهوري
محمد المنشاوي باعتقادك ااا كيف سينعكس
هذا الامر على الرئيس الامريكي وعلى ما
يبقى من ولايتها الان
باتجاه الجمهوريين الى السيطره على مجلس
النواب
بهذه الاغلبيه البسيطه في مجلس النواب
واذا تم انتخاب كيف الماركسي كزعيم
للاغلبيه الجمهوريه لن يستطيع تمرير اي اا
تشريعات ذات اهميه همم كل ما سيستطيع
القيام به هو
التنقيص على الرئيس هو ربما فتح بعض
التحقيقات حوله حول همم الانسحاب السيء من
افغانستان وربما تحقيقات حول الفساد ابنه
هانتر همم ولن يكون هناك اي تاثير على جلد
السياسيه الاجنده السياسيه تجمد في
العامين المقبلين واعترض انها الرئيس
هيكون لها حجه او حجه همم انه يبرر عدم
انجازه التشريعي بس الاغلبيه الجمهوريه
التي تقف امام اي تصور او اي اجنده جيده
له في سنتين الاخيرتين من فتره حكم الاولى
ترامب دخل هذه المعركه الانتخابيه برهانات
عده لكن العديد من المرشحين الذين دعم
دعمهم لم يحالفهم النجاح وهم يطرحوا اسئله
بشان مستقبل ترامب السياسي وفرص ترشح
للرئاسه عن الحزب الجمهوري في عام 2020
اخرجه الحدث دونالد ترامب يظهر من جديد
دون ان يملا الصوره وحده فلم يعد الرئيس
الذي كان وانما هو الطامح للعوده الى
الرئاسه من بوابه نصر ينشده في انتخابات
النصريه
المحوريه في جهود حزبه الانتخابيه
مرشحا جمهوريا لا يبدو مستعدا لتلقي اللون
على هزيمه اي منهم
والله
في حال فوزهم سيعود الفضل كله لي واذا
هزموا فلا ينبغي لهم على الاطلاق لكن عاده
ما يحدث العكس انا مستعد لاي شيء وسندافع
عن انفسنا الدفاع هنا عن خياراته ورهاناته
لخوض معارك انتخابيه بدت لكثيرين معاركه
الخاصه في كثير منها لم يتحقق النصر الذي
تمناه
كثير من مرشحه المفضلين والمؤيد كثير منهم
كما يعتقد لاجدده حركه ماركه
كسب الديمقراطيون مقعدا حاسما لسيطره على
مجلس الشيوخ بفوز جون فترمان الذي يتعافى
من جلطه دماغيه في ولايه بنسلفانيا ذات
الاهميه الانتخابيه الكبرى
كان فوزا على حساب المرشح الذي اختاره
دونالد ترامب بعنايه الدكتور مهماد في
واحده من اكثر المعارك تنافسيه في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه
جدا من دونالد ترامب
هزيمه كبرى امام الديمقراطي
جورجانيه
اريزونا الديمقراطيه كثيره
حتى اكبر انتصارات الجمهوريين حين تاتي
تابى ان تحمل توقيع ترامب فكيف اذا كان
الانتصار المدوي من نصيب منافسه المحتمل
على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري لرئاسيه 2424
بنتيجه مبهره
لن يجد ترامب في فوز الرجل ما يستدعي
لاحتفال اما نتائج بقيه من دعم ترشحهم فلا
يبدو انها تخدم خطته لخوض السباق الرئاسي
المقبل
ان يجعل من انتخابات الكونغرس المصريه
نقطه ارتكاز لاطلاق حملته بعد ايام
المقربون منه ما زالوا يعتقدون بقدرته على
تدجير كل حظا عاثر لمصلحته
نعود الى ضيوفنا محمد المنشاوي كيف يمكن
تقييم ما حدث مع ترامب يعني معظم المرشحين
الذين دعمهم حتى الان خسروا في هذه
الانتخابات ماذا يقول لنا هذا الامر
ارهقهم الخطاب السياسي ابو الطرف للرئيس
ترامب جربه الرئيس ترامب فتره حكم واحده
وانتهت نهايه كارثه الانتخابات
الاخيره هو اقتحام انصاره لمبنى الكابيتل
وعدم ادانته لهذه
الحادثه الكبرى في التاريخ الامريكي على
عكس كل المؤسسه الجمهوريه الكل ادانا هذا
الحادث العنيف الغير مظبوط في السياسه
الامريكيه الا الرئيس ترامب وهو انصاره
فاعترض ان الناخب الامريكي المستقل الذي
لا يتمتع بولاء كبير للجمهوريه او
الديمقراطيين عقب الرئيس ترامب ومرشحين
على هذه على هذا الخطا الكبير جدا
عقاب لترامب من جانب جمهور الجمهور
الامريكي
الناخبين الامريكيين والناخبين الذين
يصوتون لصالح الجمهوريين كيف سيتعاطى
باعتقادك الحزب مع ذلك
بشكل مباشر سوف ندخل في جدار حول ترشيح
شخصيه للانتخابات الرئاسيه في العام 2024
انا اتفق مع ما قيل بنسبه الى ان دونالد
ترامب هو الخاسر الاكبر ودي سانتوس هو
الكسب الاكبر وهو مرشح محتمل في 2024
باضافه الى ذلك عدد كبير من المرشحين
الذين اختارهم ربحوا في التمهيديه وخسروا
في الانتخابات العامه لماذا لان مقاربه
دونالد ترامب تقضي بتصليط الضوء على
الاشخاص الذين هم معه
هؤلاء ومهاجمه الاخرين لربما هذا يؤدي الى
نتيجه ايجابيه بنسبه اليها في المغلقه
ولكن في انتخابات عامه هذا ما ادى الى
الخساره
كيف يراقب الحزب الديمقراطي هذا الامر
بكل وضوح نحن نراقب نحن نخرج
ونراقب ما سوف يقوم به الجمهوريه
هذه
البلاد
والحزب الديمقراطيسي
الديمقراطيون لطالما طالبوا في خلال هذه
الانتخابات من الجمهوريين
بتصفيه صفوفهم ممن يدعمون من قام بالسادس
من يناير بالتالي هل هذا التوجه
يرضيهم لدى التوجه
يقلل من قلقهم
بالنسبه الى
ما اذا كان سوف يكون هناك تعاون مع
الكونجرسين ان نصلي عليه همم اعتقدوا انما
سوف يحصل بنسبه الى الديمقراطيين في
الاشهر سته الى المقبله سوف يكون هناك
فرصه
سوف يتعين عليها ان يتعاون مع الاداره
شكرا لكم
ومحمد المنشاوي على هذه المشاركه معنا
مشاهدينا بهذا نصل الى ختام هذه النافذه
عوده الى الدوحه وبقيه ملفات الحصاد على
ان نعود اليكم في منتصف الليل تغطياتنا
مستمره شكرا لمتابعتكم
[موسيقى]
شكرا نانسي وشكرا عثمان وكل فريق التغطيه
في الولايات المتحده وطبعا في انتظار
النتائج الرسميه عندما تعلم وتداعياتها
الان الى ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا وتطورات
هناك في اعلان لافته امر وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويغو بسحب القوات الروسيه
من الضفه اليمنى من نهر دنيبر في خرسن
واقامه خط دفاعا للقوات الروسيه على طول
الضفه اليسرى للنهار
في اقل من سبعه اشهر على دخول القوات
الروسيه مقاطعه خرسن في اوكرانيا وبعد قصف
المدمر
فيها لم يكاد يستقر غبار المعركه التي
تشهدها المدينه حتى جاء النبا الجيش
الروسي عن الانسحاب من غير سند واحده من
اربعه اقاليم اوكرانيه
وفرض فيها الاحكام العرفيه لاحقا امر
الجيش الروسي
على الضفه المقابله من نهر
القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا انه لم يعد من
الممكن ايصال الامدادات الى مدينه خرسون
واضاف انه اقترح اقامه خطوط دفاعيه على
الضفه اليسرى للنهار
دفاعيه على طول الضفه اليسرى ابني برو
اعرف ان هذا قرار صعب للغايه في الوقت
نفسه سنحافظ على ارواح جنودنا والفعاليه
القتاليه بشكل عام وهو امر لا جدوى منه في
منطقه محدوده على الضفه اليمنى ويعني ذلك
ان القوات الروسيه ستنسحب بشكل كامل من
الضفه اليمنى لنهر دي برو وتمثل الخطوه
تطور اللافتا لانها الاولى من نوعها
منذ سيطره قوه الروسيه على المقاطعه في
مارس اثار الماضي
وتقود قوات الجيش الاوكراني هجوم المضاد
للسعاده مدينه خرسون ذات الموقع
الاستراتيجي على الضفه اليسرى لنهار دي
برو بالقرب من المصاب البحر الاسود
بالطريق نحو شبه جزيره القرم التي تحتلها
روسيا منذ عام 2014
سهله لان المدينه محصنه بشكل جيد منذ
سيطره الروسيه عليها في بدايه الحرب على
اوكرانيا
وفي رد الفعل الاوكراني على الخطوه
الروسيه في خرسن نقلت وكاله رويترز عن
مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بدو
اياك قوله انه من المبكر الحديث عن انسحاب
الروسي من خيرسون مشيرا الى وجود قوات
الروسيه ما زالت في خرسون حتى اللحظه وقال
ابو دياك لرويترز ان بلاده لا تعيره
اهتماما للتصريحات الروسيه والافعال تختلف
عن الاقوى
ومعنى الان هنا في الاستديو اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك هنا معنا في الاستديو اذا
الاقوال تختلف عن الافعال
ما المقصود تحديدا لماذا هذا التشكيك من
الجانب الاوكراني برايك
الان هذا القرار هو غير مفاجئ لكثير من
المتابعين وخلال الاسابيع الماضيه كان
الحديث يدور حول انسحاب متوقع ولكن توقيت
الانسحاب هو المفاجاه والطريقه التي سينفذ
بها غير معروفه حتى هذه اللحظه ان ياتي
قرار الانسحاب بهذه الصوره الحديث كي او
كافه المحللين كان يتوقعوا ان هناك معركه
حاسمه ان هناك معركه حتى تبلغ درجه ما
يطلق عليها كسر العظم لماذا لانهاك القوات
المهاجمه وعدم منح الفرصه
للاحتفاظ بالزمام المبادئه ومحاوله تحقيق
جاءت لاحقه لكن جاء هذا القرار واهله مكه
ادرا بشعابها كان هناك توضيحات لهذا
الاسباب الان لماذا هذا التشكيك في
الانسحاب ساجيب عليها اولا عندما تصدر
اوامر الانسحاب هذا التوجيه عام على
المستوى الاستراتيجيه العسكريه هذا جاء من
وزير الدفاع بناء على ايجاز قدم من قبل
القائد المعني ولكن هذا القائد هو قائد
منطقه العمليه والمنطقه الكليه لمنطقه
القتال ولكن هذا القاطع تحديدا هناك قاضي
دون هذا القائد الذي اصدر هذا الامر
وبالتالي الخطه التي يتم تبنيها من اجل
الانسحاب توضع من قبل القاده الاخرين ضمن
التوجيه وبالانه امامهم ثلاثه خيارات اما
ان يكون انسحاب مدبر وهذا يتخذ ويحتاج وقت
ويحتاج اجراءات او ان يكون قتال اعاقه او
ان يكون انسحاب فوضوي اقرب الى الهزيمه
هذا السبب حتى هذه اللحظه ما هي
ميكانيكيات الانسحاب لم تحدد بعد اذا كان
انسحابا مدبرا قد يكون القائد في بعض
الحالات يريد ان يوقع خشائر يريد ان يحتفظ
بقوته متزنه قد تاخذ ايام او اسابيع واذا
كان انسحابا فوضيا قد ياخذ ساعات او ايام
معدوده اذا الصوره الميدانيه غير واضحه
للجانب الاوكراني اذا ثلاث سنوات
ولكن ما سبق الانسحاب هو طلب لاجراء
السكان ثم الانسحاب
هل لهذه التفصيل اهميه هنا وهل له دلاله
مثلا في ان ترجح احد هذه السيناريوهات
الان هو لا تستطيع ان اقول لانه حتى وجهه
النظر مختلفه ما بين الجانب الروسي
والجانب الاوكراني الجانب الاوكراني كان
يتحدث عن تهجير قذف وانزامي واجبارهم على
الخروج
حيث التوقيت الجانب الروسي كان يتحدث
بطريقه مغاره ان هو من اجل تخفيف الخسائر
الى غير ذلك اما الان تم اجلاء حوالي
80,000 وبالتالي تعتبر المنطقه خالي من
السكان الا من ابى او اختفى الان انا
اتحدث عن ميكانيكيات معركه ميكانيكيه
المعركه المنطق العسكري يقول انه لابد من
ان يكون انسحابا مدبر له ميكانيكياته له
اجراءاته ياخذ وقتا يوقع خسائر تنسحب
القوات وهي بحاله اتزان لتنتقل من موقع
قتالي الى موقع اخر واستدادات الى تصريحات
القائد الروسي قال ان من المهام
المستقبليه هو بناء خط الدفاعيه
واستخدامها في عمليات هجوم محدود وامكانيه
توظيفه في مناطق اخرى هذا هذا الكلام اذا
انا كمحلل اعتمدته اقول يجب ان يكون
الانسحاب مدبر حتى تبقى القوات متزنه
وقادره على تنفيذ المهام المست بان بقى في
حاله الانسحاب السريع قد يتحول الى هزيمه
هذا القوات تفقد اتزانها ولا يمكن توظيفها
مستقبلا والتشكيك الاوكراني يصب في فرضيه
انه انسحاب مدبله على العموم حتى تتضح
الامور بشكل اكمل طبعا هذا ما لدينا الان
سنتابع اي هذه السيناريوهات ربما هو
الارجح على العموم نشكر الجزيره
قال السفير الروسي لدى
واشنطنوس من المهم الحفاظ على الاتصالات
مع الولايات المتحده لمنع تصعيد لا يمكن
التنبؤ بعواقبه واضافه لا تتخذ اي خطوه
للاستئنا في الحوار بشان الاستقرار
الاستراتيجي الذي انطلق العمل الماضي
كذلك اوضح انه لا يمكن للبيت الابيض
الافلات من المسؤوليه عن اطاله امد الصراع
في اوكرانيا واشار الراس في الروسي في
واشنطن الى ان الولايات المتحده تستمر
باسرار جنونيه في ما وصفها بحرب استنزاف
ترهق روسيا واوكرانيا واوروبا
[موسيقى]
الان الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث استشهد
فلسطينيان برصاص قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله احدهما شاب في
قريه عنين غربيه جنين الاخر فتن في
الخامسه عشره من العمر اصيب في اشتباكات
اندلعت خلال زياره نواب اسرائيليين
يمينيين لموقع قبر يوسف شرق مدينه نابلس
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله تتواصل الهجمه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه احدث فصولها غربيه
جنين حيث استشهد شاب رافت علي عبد الله
عيسى برصاص جيش الاحتلال بعد ان ترك ينزف
نحو ساعه من الزمن دون اسعاف قبل ذلك
بساعات استشهد الفتى مهدي محمد حشاش ذو 15
عاما خلال اقتحام قوات اسرائيليه مدينه
نابلس حيث داره اشتباكات المسلحه في محيط
قبر يوسف في الجزء الشرقي من المدينه وقد
كان جيش الاحتلال يؤمن زياره الموقع
لاعضاء اسرائيليين في الكنيسه بينهم اعضاء
من حزب اليكود ومن تحالف الصهيونيه
الدينيه اليمني المتطرف
موكب تشيع الفتى الشهيد الى مخيم بلاطه
للاجئين تحول الى مسيره غاضبه رفع خلالها
المشيعون الفلسطينيه واطلقه تافات مندده
بالانتهاكات الاسرائيليه بينما اطلق
مسلحون النار في الهواء
انتهاكات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم تتوقف
يوما لكنها منذ بدايه العام الحالي 2022
اخذت منحا تصعيديا لاسيا في الضفه الغربيه
من حيث عمليات القتل والاقتحامات
والمداهمات والاعتقالات
ووفقا لوزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ارتفع عدد
الشهداء برصاص جيش الاحتلال الى
144 شهيدا بينهم 133 في الضفه بما فيها
القدس وواحد وخمسون في قطاع غزه وخلال نفس
الفتره اي منذ بدايه العام الحالي افاد
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني الشهر ان جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نفذ نحو خمسه الاف
وثلاثمائه عمليه اعتقال منذ مطلع العام
الجاري والمؤكد ان العدد اكثر من ذلك الان
بالنظر الى حملات الاعتقار الاسرائيليه
المستمره يوميا وقد شملت يوم الاربعاء
لوحده 14 فلسطينيه من مدن وبلدات الضفه
الغربيه المحتله بما فيها القدس
وبينما تتواصل في جنيف اعمال جلسات لجنه
الامم المتحده الخاصه بالنزاع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي للاستماع للضحايا قررت السلطه
الفلسطينيه مناشداتها للمجتمع الدولي لوقف
اسرائيل عن انتهاكاتها الواسعه
انتهاكات تنظر برغبه الاحتلال في التهام
الضفه وتقويض السلطه والانقضاض على ما
تبقى من فلسطين وهو توجه من المرتقب ان
يتعزز اكثر مع قدوم حكومه جديده برئاسه
بنيامين نتنياهو توصف لاكثر حكومات
يمينيه وتطرفا في تاريخ الصراع
ومن الجليل معنى الدكتور محمد خلايله
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه حيفا
والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه الدكتور محمد اهلا بك في
الحصاد اذا سابدا من حيث انتهى التقرير
هذا التصعيد يتزامن مع قدوم حكومه يفترض
انها الاكثر يمينيه في تاريخ الصراع ما
الذي يمكن ان اتوقع
الحكومه
ايام القريبه القادمه
تحمل بداخلها مركبات يمنيه
عقائديه همم تجمع بين طياتها نزعل من
التشرد القومي بالاضافه الى التزمت الديني
وهذا سيعكس بالضروره على يعني الصراع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني اولا من حيث يعني
الممارسات الاحتياليه الاستيطان ومحاوله
يعني تقويه السلطه ومحاوله ايضا تغيير
الوضع القائم وايضا على المستوى همم
الاسرائيلي الداخل من حيث تغيير البنيه
الدستوريه نحن تعميق
الدوله اليهوديه من الناحيه القوميه
والناحيه الدينيه
ومحاوله يعني تعزيز يعني حاجه
رائع اطفاء معاني دستوريه جديده لها بشان
الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني يعني الم
الذي رايناه اليوم وهمم بالامس وايضا انه
نواب في البرلمان الاسرائيلي يقومون يعني
بانفسهم
باخذ مستمر للفلسطينيين بالتاكيد
للفلسطينيين هذه الممارسه تشهد تصاعدا
باعتقاد الفتره القريبه القادمه نظرا لانه
يعني هذه الشخصيات عادت الى يعني وسلمت
مقاليد السلطه
اذا سمحتي فقط
في العاده كان ينظر للتصعيد على انه ورقه
سياسيه همم يستخدمها المرشحون للانتخابات
وما الى ذلك هل فعلا هناك حاجه ملحه الان
هل ينظر اليها كورقه تستخدم الان بعد ان
يعني ننتظر اسبوعين وتتشكل حكومه جديده
يعني ما الذي سيترتب على هذا الان الى اين
يسير التصعيد
يعني الموضوع ليس فقط موضوع يعني محاوله
استخدام
ورقه ضاغطه على يعني مسار تشكيل الحكومه
يعني هذه الاحزاب وهذه الشخصيات لوحه يعني
بمشروها مشروع عميقا
من يعني القضيه الفلسطينيه ومحاوله يعني
المطابقه بين الروايه التوراهيه التي ترى
يعني بارض اسرائيل الكبرى هي مشروحه
السياسه او اسرائيل يعني هذه ليست مجرد
يعني او ممارسات خارجه وطارئه يعني تهدف
الى تحصيل اكبر عدد من المنجزات او
المقدرات السياسيه في هذه
هذا سيكون هو الاطار الضابط لهذه الحكومه
لانها حكومه تحمل بين طياتها مركبات فاشيه
عنصريه بين يعني هذه مشرف
الظاهر ادى استيائه من هذا العنصر سواء
اثمار بنخفيض تحديدا كان هناك كثير من
المنتقدين له في الخارج المجتمع الدولي
الولايات المتحده تحديدا كيف ستتعامل مع
هذا المعطى الجديد خصوصا ان السلطه ناشدت
المجتمع الدولي ان يتحرك هل لهذا اي تاثير
يعني طبيعي يعني دور الولايات المتحده
يتمحور في اطار الضغط السياسي على اسرائيل
ولكن نحن نعرف انه منذ استلام جميله ياهو
رئاسه الحكومه وهو ياخذ اسرائيل الى حاله
احتدام معين مع السياسات الخارجيه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهو الذي لوحه
يعني في الانتخابات السابقه انه الوحيد
الذي استطاع ان يضرب
بعرض الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
ويعني الموضوع في نهايه المطاف يعني
دخل الحكومه تشير انه لدى اسرائيل السياده
الكامله والاستقلاليه الكامله وهي التي
تحدث اثناء قراراتها
عن العوامل الدوليه
من الجليل استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
حيفا والخبير في شؤون الاسرائيليه
الى ايران الان حيث خرج التجمعات احتجاجيه
مساء الاربعاء في كل من طهران ومشهد ورشط
وشهر كورد واسفهان وسندج تاتي هذه
التجمعات بمناسبه مرور 40 يوما على سقوط
قتل الاحتجاجات في مدينه زهيدان في محافظه
سيستان وبلوشيستان ورددا المحتجون شعارات
تطالب بالحريه وتردد بسياسات النظام في
ايران كما اقيمت في بعض المناطق مراسم
وتضامن مع قتل احتجاجات محافظات سيستان
وبلوستان
هذا وعدنا المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني بيانا مجموعه الدول
السبع وقال ان الاتهامات التي وجهت لايران
هي ادعاءات وهي لا اساس لها من الصحه
واضاف انما صدر في البيان بشان الاوضاع
الداخليه في ايران يتعارض ومقررات الامم
المتحده ويشجع على اعمال الشغب والعمليات
الارهابيه داخل ايران وانا على الدول
السبعه تحمل مسؤوليتها واوضح ان اتهام
ايران بارسال طائرات وسيارات الى روسيا
الى اساس له مؤكدا ان ايران اساسه الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وانها ستواصل
التعامل لها البناء مع الدول الجوار وشدد
على التزام بلاده بتعهداتها في الاتفاق
النووي وانها كانت لا تزال مستعده
لمفاوضات المنطقيه للتوصل الى اتفاق قويا
ومستدى من يضمن حقوق الشعب الايراني
انتهى الحصاد الليله تصبحون على الف خير
[موسيقى]